[Music]  we all know the magic mushroom houses in  the tight white pants excuse me but what  if they were more to the story I saw  someone who looked like us but it's the  lost villages in the legend I was wrong  if there really are other Smurfs  doubtful we need to find them whatever  you do don't eat all your rations I just  write all my Russian is this Wow Wow Wow  we have to find the village before they  do I'll be like grabber oh they'll be  all like funny that's what I call  talking out of your butt  I'm really freaking out you guys Smurfs  the lost village worrywart sometimes I  just feel blue krang's shade throwers  nosey so what's going on over there and  there's one thing they have in common  100 good old do